so in recent times I've seen the rise of
top anime list that detailed the anime
that many people would recommend anime
fans to watch but I have yet to see
anything close representing more anime
fans actually end up watching so if you
yourself want to be considered a
well-rounded respectable anime fan [ __ ]
all those other lists telling you what
you need to see this is the actual top
20 anime that every anime fan needs to
watch or like you're probably not a real
anime fan HD number 20 sword art online
starting off this list is of course the
classic sword art online which has been
on everyone's to watch this ever since
it first aired in the summer of 2012 now
under absolutely no circumstances should
you actually enjoy sword art online but
you need to watch it too basically [ __ ]
on anyone who does yes the easiest way
to make friends and get popular is just
to talk about how bad soil art online
was even if you didn't think it was as
bad as everyone says become the life of
the party by calling cadiz oh and eddie
self-insert Opie douchebag and that the
first half was so much better than the
second half and I guarantee that you
will be one of the cool kids
number 19 a Ghibli film come on everyone
loves Ghibli films even people who hate
anime love Ghibli films so you need to
love Ghibli too I mean everyone knows
Miyazaki [ __ ] hates anime and wanted
like 50 more hiroshima 's so maybe it
doesn't even count as anime just make
sure you watch all the ones you need to
watch I'm talking spirited away Princess
Mononoke and literally any other Ghibli
film to make it seem like you're not an
uncultured [ __ ] who's only seen spirited
away and Princess Mononoke number 18
Anan Ghibli film that is not akira or
ghost in the show that's right general
public there are other anime films that
exist you know there's that film by that
guy who made Digimon films oh that guy
who died too early and that guy who
makes everything look really pretty
whatever the names are it's probably not
important number 17 an old anime let's
get this straight
what anime sucks and everyone knows it
I mean it's a universally proven fact
that anything made before the age of
digital animation looks got ugly and
isn't worth your time have a further
back you go the worse it gets but you'll
always encounter that one fan who's
about your dad
Zaid reminiscing about that time he
watched may cross for some 90's ova
literally no one has ever heard of his
50th generation versa recording whatever
that is so you always need to be able to
say something like yeah
Astro Boy was my favorite anime growing
up too and he'll probably leave you
alone number 16 Shara Barker this one is
more for the critics or the ones who
want to be more knowledgeable about the
industry as a whole I mean you could do
your own research on the inner workings
of the anime industry to be
well-informed and everything but [ __ ]
all that
just watch Shura Barker and you're now
have a PhD in anime production so your
opinion when I'll be infinitely more
well informed that anyone else who
hasn't seen it bonus points if you're so
red vacuum on and have become an expert
on manga artists to number 15 the
nostalgic shows you watched as a kid ah
yes well you a 90s kid who grew up on
Pokemon and Dragonball Z does old-school
Toonami bring nothing but Joy's memories
to you maybe he came a bit later when
the root--so bleach in one piece were
getting popular either way these are the
shows that will always be close to you
no matter what anyone else says hell you
don't even know if they were as great as
you remember it but that's okay
you were a dumb naive kid back then and
you had [ __ ] tastes but at least you can
reflect on it now that you're older and
wiser with an equally [ __ ] taste number
14 a hentai yes we're all [ __ ] tired
of the rest of the world thinking that
every anime you watch is sometimes
called raping freak show and that every
time your mom walks in the room is
guaranteed to be that one scene where
that girl trips over exposing her
massive tits you can spend your entire
lifetime explaining that anime is a wide
and varied medium containing some of the
most compelling series of all time but
it also provides a unique platform for
storytelling her real talk here right
guys everyone's watch hentai leaves one
tear even the girls just remember her
the most important rule of all we're
never allowed to discuss it or ever
admit that we have in public no one must
ever know
number 13 legend of the Galactic Heroes
now this one is actually a trick one
because no one actually needs to watch
legend of the Galactic Heroes they just
need to say they want to watch it see
once you watch legend of the Galactic
Heroes there is no going back as an
anime fan as every anime you watch from
then on will be utter trash compared to
it and you will quite literally stand
above everyone who has not
see in legend of the Galactic Heroes so
if you're not yet prepared to ascend to
the next plane yet just say yeah like
I'll definitely watch it one day number
12
an anime where you argue over best girl
you're not a true anime fan unless
you've argued over which girl in a
particular series is indeed best girl
forget politics forget religion you have
not seen full conflict until you see a
group of nerds argue over which
fictional 2d character has the most
hypothetically appealing trace in a
made-up cast of an anime blood is shed
friendships are lost and this is the
place where you find your true brothers
an arm but the one irrefutable fact that
you must stick by is that anyone who
does not agree review has [ __ ] tastes
conversely once you get bored of
fighting the never-ending best girl Wars
come watch an Auto Show to see that a
perfectly peaceful utopian society can't
exist in the real world number 11
something with boobies because boobies
number 10 that's one hot anime that
everyone is watching every season you
know the one I mean that one that
everyone is exclusively talking about
because apparently no one is watching
anything else this season it doesn't
matter if you are you won't find anyone
else to talk about it with anyway so you
might as well get on the hype train to
see what all the fuss is about just be
prepared for the shitstorm that comes
after it ends you've got it either love
it or think is an absolute piece of
overhyped [ __ ] cuz any other opinion
doesn't count but don't worry it'll all
blow over in about two weeks anyway
because everyone's already moved on to
new season then all you have to do is
pick the next hot anime coming out and
repeat the cycle once again for ever but
before you do that you need to watch
number 10 point 5 the 50 anime you'll
pick up at the start of every season 2
then drop after three episodes come on
it's the start of the season everything
looks good everything has potential I
mean you're watching shows you wouldn't
normally watch but it could be good rice
II gotta get an impression then after 2
or 3 episodes you realize what a stupid
idiot you've been trying to keep up with
50 episodes every week and just continue
to watch the same old [ __ ] you always
end up watching you on original pleb
number 9 avatar the last airbender one
of the greatest anime to ever exist that
everyone remembers growing up with on TV
Oh what this isn't actually an anime
that
I'll be right I mean it looks like an
anime feels like an anime and sounds
like an anime so who cares where it's
made right I mean god forbid we classify
this as a cartoon does this look like
[ __ ] Family Guy to you
ya know number eight boku no pico and
Cory in the house I'd be remiss if I
didn't include the university agreed
masterpieces that are boku no pico and
Cory in the house these two classics
have weaved the way into anime culture
revolutionising the way we see modern
anime cementing themselves as the I'm
just [ __ ] kidding guys I'm putting
this here too a piece of people Arthur
overuse jokes hash tag Here Come that
boy Harambee number seven Gundam if
you're an anime founder for any extended
period of time you will inevitably run
into the Gundam fan so it's important
that you can hold a respectful
conversation with them but actually
becoming a proper Gundam fan and
watching all the Gundams will take you
about 50 billion 3927 hours three
sittings of The Lord of the Rings
trilogy and a game of dota 2 so what you
really need to do is watch a Gundam show
any Gundam show doesn't matter which one
I mean they're all basically at the same
show anyway you got giant robots
politics giant robot the important thing
is you now have a favorite Gundam so
when a Gundam fan asks you which one
your favorite one is you can always
answer the correct I Saurabh the best
one he'll know exactly which one you
mean right Gundam fans and if they do
ask which is your favorite Gundam
timeline simply answer yes number six
Cowboy Bebop ever since it first aired
on Adult Swim this show has become an
instant classic for Western anime fans
but is it a must watch because of its
memorable characters excellent
soundtrack choice definitively cool
style [ __ ] no it's a must watch so that
makes some you meet a sub elitist who
claims all dubs are [ __ ] it's the one
show you can rub right in our ugly face
that's universally irrefutable number
five attack on Full Metal Death Note
punch man that's right it's a definitive
best-selling anime series of everyone's
[ __ ] scene and likes including you
just remember you always have to have
one of these in your top ten favorite
anime but you are absolutely not allowed
to have them as your number one cause
everyone else likes them so you
be seen as an unoriginal [ __ ] number 4
episode 3 of Madoka Magica I don't know
I guess something big is supposed to
happen than this episode I mean everyone
keeps talking about to this day I don't
I'm [ __ ] on number 3 a high school
anime look it's not a proper anime
unless it's set in high school if it's
not then you know the characters are
high school age by becoming an anime fan
you basically attend the Japanese high
school yourself I mean you'll be an
expert in attending opening ceremonies
organizing school festivals and sitting
in the backseat of a classroom by the
window don't forget that this will also
mean that you've seen a lot of
slice-of-life anime see slice-of-life is
a completely unique genre that only
exists in anime which means no one
actually knows what the [ __ ] it properly
means so if it's set in high school it
probably has some slice-of-life
elements in it and everyone [ __ ]
loves that number too Neon Genesis
Evangelion definitely one of the most
influential anime to ever come out every
fan knows that one day they must
eventually watch Neon Genesis Evangelion
in order to have an opinion on Neon
Genesis Evangelion whether you love it
hate it don't get the ending or
understand every intricate detail I can
write a 50 page thesis deconstructing it
even if all you really care about is
who's best girl between Oscar and Rey
it is imperative that you have an
opinion on it because it'll be the topic
of discussion for approximately the next
7 trillion years number 1 your favorite
anime that didn't make this list look
guys I know that this is the actual top
20 anime that every fan needs to watch
and the fact that your personal favorite
anime didn't make this list is an
absolute travesty it doesn't matter that
I might not have seen the anime yet or I
don't think it's as great as you do and
that is impossible to have a list that
matches everyone's tastes your anime
should have been here and I obviously
don't know what I'm talking about so
please be sure to leave a million
comments telling me about that one anime
amidst and leave a dislike so I
recognize the greatness of the anime
that I missed
which I definitely will offer you do you
know what you should do that even if
your favorite anime was on its list but
not at number one and that was it
hope you've now learned something about
yourself as an anime fan because as per
the title of this video if you haven't
seen absolutely everything
on us list then obviously you're not a
real anime fan yeah oh just like watch
whatever you want to watch I'm not your
[ __ ] mother hey guys apologies my
camera is still being fixed later get
see my lovely face just yet thank you
very much this month - Gabe brown Thomas
P Vincent Mooney
Loretta Roy and everyone on patreon for
health and making these videos possible
I'm also having a special double
giveaway this month for my patrons so go
check it out if you want those your
underwear I'm also staying in my Asian
house for a few months so hello from
Thailand I don't get to see many white
people here anyway that's it for me
though check out my other stuff if this
is your first time here but apart from
that I've been gig ugh and I'll see you
all next time